[Music]
Raju - hurry it's me
train with them go before best animals
to death with those actions
she's tackling the pending right
how many times do I have to tell her
don't trade alone but only embeds your
errands bring our young damsel to the
Lord for joy she wants to practice
she'll get
to get mad at her why the hell not the
whippersnapper refuses to do as she's
told you like that about her
fine this one's an apartment blame this
has to wait
big monsters is not something to be
taken like here ciri must understand
that seems to occur
I'll see you go
[Applause]
wrong now I see why you were so eager to
practice strike
[Music]
Serkis Bureau it what do you think all
right take off the blindfold you've got
work to do
your reflexes are still slow maybe for a
Witcher think drowners or Stricker's
we'll go easy on you because you haven't
undergone the mutations though in your
shoes I'd fear vesemir more than a nice
trigger disobeying his instructions
unwise yes horribly dull I know and you
know that's no excuse I'm sorry
won't happen again
sorry's not good enough you're gonna
read ghouls and al Ghul's in its
entirety appendices included please
clean the stables end of discussion
come on we'll practice with the others
down below shall we run the walls
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's good yeah
come out
[Music]
gulps that was close I was sure I'd end
up like my man provided you got lucky
your horse died quickly
but Griffins like to toy with their prey
in its alive piece-by-piece
you'd like a reward I suppose
[Music]
you don't owe us anything
and they call witches partners say they
won't lift a finger without pay
they also say mice
[Music]
like I said it's the main road and
Enslin muttered you seek someone
[Music]
yes a woman medium height long black
hair seen anyone like that no but
there's an in here in Y tortured soul
one around gets its share of travelers
perhaps we learn something there
besides the ink keeps my cousin tell her
Bram sent you that she'll treat you like
family
not a bad idea especially since that
wound needs cleaning beasts barely
grazed but sure use a good wry nice pool
you know straight from the cellar
stream and the waves of grain
place
[Music]
I know how to choose them so
[Music]
let's start
good
[Music]
now what we have to do is wait come on
we can cower in the shade of those
birches
[Music]
so tell me once we find yennefer what do
we do
contract no I'll go to care more that
live it is setting into the winter snows
are way off yes that's what worries no
cards crossed the pond town at least
puts them in a week's march from care
morning if they reach the valley before
snows can cover the passes
need to cover our tracks by plans
we return Wittering think you'll come
this year maybe might bring a guest
[Music]
it's close
[Music]
Cosmo won it in a card game while you
run around might come in handy
that should have some evils but you're
gambling self stop talking got a Griffin
detail
not bad not bad though you could stand
to improve subjects
man spends his whole life learning not a
Witcher and I see this one
but more on that later take the Griffons
heavy the black ones already are horses
made me at the end
[Music]
you